und dann ist die Frage ist man hier mit
seinem Standard in Bayern noch
wettbewerbsfähig
perverserweise haben wir auch einige
Arbeitsplätze in Bayern dadurch verloren
ich sehe eine politische Wende ich sehe
eine praktische wende ich sehe aber eine
viel zu geringe Geschwindigkeit Bayern
Wirtschaftsleistung fast wie die gesamte
Schweiz
Industriestandort und
windradwüste und das könnte sich rächen
der Strom bald vielleicht teurer die
Industrie stöhnt Windkraft wird
Standortfaktor verscheucht Bayern seine
Wirtschaft also jemanden wie ihn
Unternehmer Dieter Pfister produziert
Rohrsysteme hier in Franken 400
Mitarbeiterinnen Export in die ganze
Welt klassischer bayerischer Mittelstand
aber wie lange noch die Strompreis
Debatte ist natürlich für uns recht
heftig und immens wichtig vor allem die
künftige Entwicklung und da sind die
Diskussion ob wir Event unterschiedliche
Strompreise auch in Deutschland bekommen
und ob das ein Anlass sein kann nach
Norddeutschland gehen zu müssen mit der
Produktion und dort den niedrigeren
Strompreis zu nutzen fester will in
Franken bleiben und planen sogar sein
eigenes Windrad damit wäre er fast
unabhängig unabhängig auch von
Diskussionen um sogenannte
strompreiszonen das Problem wird viel
produziert der Norden günstig Strom doch
auf dem Weg in den Süden Stau der sich
Leitungen fehlen auch das ein
bayerisches Versäumnis das muss dann mit
Gaskraftwerken teuer ausgeglichen werden
das kostet Milliarden im Jahr der Preis
in ganz Deutschland steigt
die strompreiszonen sollen das lösen
nur da wo der Strom günstig produziert
wird soll er auch günstig verkauft
werden so schlägt es eine EU-Behörde vor
Teil für den Norden mit seinen
Windrädern
Nachteil für Bayern und die
energiehungrige Industrie
in anderen Ländern gibt es solche
Preiszonen bereits ExpertInnen halten
den Vorschlag auch in Deutschland für
effektiv politisch aber schwer umsetzbar
sorgen umsteigende Strompreise sie
hängen immerhin schon jetzt über den
Produktionszahlen dann kann es schon ins
Minus rutschen dass man also Verlust
macht oder der Gewinn ausbleibt und
damit künftige Investition nicht mehr
möglich sind recht sich jetzt Bayern
Stillstands bei der Windkraft das
Arbeitgeber nahe Institut für Wirtschaft
glaubt ja die Wirtschaft im Süden
brauchen mehr Windräder in einer Umfrage
geben zwei Drittel der Unternehmen an
die Perspektive der Grünen
Energieversorgung sah hier schlecht
auch auf zdf-nachfrage sagen die meisten
Bundesländer grüner Strom ist
Standortfaktor für die Industrie Bayern
selbst gesteht es ist aktuell
feststellbar das gerade viele
wirtschaftsvereinigungen und anlässige
Unternehmen im Freistaat vermehrt auf
den Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien drängen
die Landesregierung sieht sich als
Vorreiter bei Ökostrom
Bayern hat nichts nachzuholen Bayern
liegt der vorne ich finde es immer ganz
interessant dass dann argumentiert wird
Bayern sehr schlecht bei erneuerbaren
wenn man den Tabellenführer quasi
vorwirft dass er Tabellenführer ist in
absoluten Service Bayern tatsächlich
weit vorne in Relation zu seiner Fläche
spielt das Land aber eher in Mittelfeld
denn bislang haben die Bayern vor allem
auf solarstromgesetzt aber Windes vor
allem halt im Herbst Winter
frühlingsstark und die Photovoltaik im
Sommer und von daher reicht es einfach
ein schlichtweg nicht aus nur auf solide
zu setzen unter winds erwähnt aber wieso
stehen dann in Bayern kaum Windräder
wir haben die schönste Landschaft in
Bayern und wir werden von allen guten
Geistern verlassen wenn man diese schöne
Natur und diese Lebensgrundlagen
zerstören
Ministerpräsident Horst Seehofer
erschwert in seiner Zeit in Ausbau
Pfister selbst CSU-Mitglied schon damals
enttäuscht ja das war für mich die
riesen Enttäuschung gewesen 2014 da war
ich als IHK-Präsident live in München
bei Ministerpräsident Seehofer dabei wir
Verständnis für die Wirtschaft gezeigt
hat wir brauchen Windkraft allerdings
eben Bedenken aus populistischen Gründen
im gegenüber den Bürgern der sagt wir
müssen diese zehn Haare Regel bringen
was nach meiner persönlichen Meinung und
viele meiner Kollegen auch falsch war
aber es kam dann so und die Konsequenz
war darauf dass windkraftanlagenbau in
Bayern zum liegen gekommen ist Bayern
hat ab 2014 den Ausbau eingeschränkt
über die berüchtigte zehn Haare Regel
plötzlich musste ein Windrad das
Zehnfache seiner Höhe an Abstand zum
nächsten Haushalt halten
es war wirklich ein sehr eleganter
Schachzug des über die Bauordnungen halt
im Endeffekt zu mir liegen zu bringen
und tot zu machen und
perverser Weise haben wir auch einige
Arbeitsplätze in Bayern dadurch verloren
weil kurz bevor diese zehn haarregelung
eingeführt wurde hat der Herr Seehofer
noch im Betonwerk von Max Bögl zu neue
Anlage eingeweiht zu Produktion von
windtürmen also es ist wirklich sehr
sehr schädlich gewesen für unsere
Industrie ein Bundesgesetz hat im
vergangenen Jahr die Landesregierung und
ihre zehn haarregelung in die Schranken
seit der Einführung der Regel war der
Ausbau der Windenergie eingebrochen von
412 Megawatt bis in den niedrigen
zweistelligen Bereich um die eigenen
Ziele einzuhalten müssten ab sofort rund
570 Megabyte installiert werden und zwar
jedes Jahr in der Praxis schwer jetzt wo
die Regeln lockerer sind kann auch
Dieter Pfister mit seinem Projekt
beginnen seit Jahren will ein eigenes
Windrad für seine Betrieb wir
unternehmen sind durchaus auch Egoisten
man macht sich unabhängig von den
strompreisentwicklungen weil der
Strompreis verändert sich von Tag zu Tag
man kann fast sagen von Stunde zu Stunde
an der strompreisbörse und wenn man dann
eigene Strom hat weiß man eben worauf
man sich verlassen kann und wir wollen
ja die Zukunft absichern wir wollen
unsere Arbeitsplätze hier in Franken
absichern weiteres Wachstum ermöglichen
Pfister dachte erst in zwei Jahren steht
ein Windrad jetzt rechnet er mit
mindestens vier Jahren wenn alles mit
den Genehmigungen klappt er und auch
sein windradplaner Glauben politisch
gibt es einen Wandel nur es Henke bei
der Verwaltung ich glaube man muss da
aufpassen dass man den Behörden
gegenüber nicht ungerecht wird denn es
gibt einfach wahnsinnig viele
Vorschriften die die in den
Genehmigungsverfahren zu beachten haben
auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich
auch immer ein mentales Thema wenn man
10 Jahre lang einen eingefahrenes System
hatte wie man auf solche Projekte guckt
dann wird man das nicht innerhalb von
Monaten aus irgendwelchen politisch ja
hervorgerufenen Gründen heraus verändern
können die töpfisters größtes Problem
Kleinflugzeuge fliegen bislang hier oben
über seiner windradfläche er schlägt vor
die Route einfach zu verschieben
die Behörden blicken hingegen auf
lärmschutzgesetze bei einer neuen Route
könnten die Flieger anderswo mehr
AnwohnerInnen
das wird deswegen eben auch die
Genehmigung versagt bekommen weil es
Luftamt Nordbayern sagt zu einem Fall
hatten wir noch nicht und dann muss
sagen ich kann nur zustimmen so einen
Fall hat mir noch nicht werden keine
Ukraine Krieg werden keine Energiekrise
wir müssen die neue Situation einfach
angehen und das auch weiter Bürokratie
bei den Ämtern wie fühlt sich das
Stocken an das ist fast ein gewohntes
Gefühl und für uns ist es eher so dass
wir jetzt uns alle umgewöhnen müssen
dass das alles viel schneller gehen soll
und das eigentlich nach meinem
Dafürhalten allen Mitstreitern in der
Windbranche genauso geht das der Glauben
daran auch ein bisschen fehlt das jetzt
alles viel schneller gehen wird
vielleicht bleibt der Platz neben meinem
Chor leer und Pfister bleibt auf seinen
teuren Plänen sitzen aber fester will
bleiben mit oder ohne Windrad